sin perder tiempo tiktok respondió a la
prohibición Estatal de Montana con una
demanda la plataforma de videos acusa al
Estado de violar el derecho a la
libertad de expresión garantizado por la
Constitución estadounidense
creemos que el proyecto de ley de
Montana aprobado recientemente Es
simplemente inconstitucional y como
usted ha señalado hemos presentado
recientemente una demanda para
impugnarlo ante los tribunales y
confiamos en que prevalecerá
la semana pasada el gobernador
republicano del Estado aprobó una ley
que ilegalizará que las tiendas de
aplicaciones ofrezcan tiktok a partir
del próximo enero en Montana ya está
prohibido en los dispositivos
gubernamentales y bloqueos similares
están en vigor en otros estados así como
en los dispositivos federales
Sí yo ya hay discusiones serias digamos
que Creo yo que más a nivel Estatal Hoy
hay discusiones serias a nivel Federal
de si se pudiese llegar a hacer esto
claramente aquí hay todo un complejo
sistema alrededor de lo que para los
norteamericanos es súper importante como
lo es la libertad de expresión y es
precisamente la razón por la cual tanto
la compañía Como algunos de los usuarios
de tiktok en Montana han demandado
a la al al Estado Estados Unidos teme
que la empresa matriz de tiktok la
tecnológica china bite Dance pueda pasar
datos de los usuarios al gobierno Chino
lo que supondría un riesgo para la
seguridad nacional Washington ha
presionado para que la empresa sea
vendida una compañía estadounidense O
podría enfrentarse a una prohibición
nacional lo que está en juego es el
destino de los generadores de contenido
y de al menos 150 millones de usuarios
de tiktok en el país